[Music]
where did covid-19 come from
some think it originated in this Wuhan
wet Market
While others think it comes from bats
but could it be possible that covid-19
was made in a lab
is it true that covid-19 is an
engineered virus
or did it accidentally Escape
this is what if and here's what would
happen if covid-19 was made in a lab
the lab that covid-19 could have escaped
from is the Wuhan Institute of virology
this lab deals with some of the most
dangerous viruses in the world and if it
did happen it wouldn't be the first time
for one of these Labs the SARS virus
escaped from high-level containment labs
in Beijing multiple times
but is this lab really where covid-19
came from
well first let's talk about why people
think covid-19 originated at this lab
the first covid-19 case was initially
found in this Wuhan wet Market
and since this wet Market is just 12
kilometers from the Wuhan virology
Center
this lab is really the only one in
question
not to mention that it's the global
epicenter of coronavirus research in
bats
since it's suspected covid-19 came from
bats there's been speculation that the
virus could have been engineered and
then accidentally escaped from the
building
and if the world were able to confirm
that this actually happened
the consequences would be pretty scary
relations between China and the rest of
the world could start to get incredibly
hostile
but hopefully we don't need to worry
about covid-19 starting any wars that's
because no covid-19 was not made in a
lab and it didn't find a way to
mysteriously sneak out of the virology
center
the Wuhan Institute of virology was
looking for something similar to covet
19. a bat disease that was harmful to
humans if researchers found anything
like that they would have published
their scientific results immediately
they wouldn't have waited for it to
escape from their labs
and it was originally reported that the
first cases of covid-19 happened in the
Wuhan wet Market but that might not be
the case
it was later determined that the first
cases had no connection to the animal
Market
so it is possible that someone outside
of Wuhan contracted the virus and
brought it into the animal Market
where it would be easy for the virus to
spread but that doesn't mean that any of
this was intentional
it's safe to say that covid-19 was not
genetically engineered
if it were there would be signs of
manipulation in the genome data and
thousands of scientists all around the
world have looked at the Genome of the
virus and haven't found any evidence of
engineering
if there had been any tampering it would
be pretty obvious
scientists would need to create their
own backbone for the DNA which can be
detected pretty quickly
not only that but being able to create a
virus that spreads disease is nearly
impossible and that's because scientists
don't know enough about what makes a
virus pathogenic just yet
and viruses are extremely complicated
in order to be able to manufacture one
scientists would need to perfectly
construct every single molecule in the
virus just one tiny aspect of the virus
altered and it could end up wildly
different
so it's safe to say that covid-19 was
not made in a lab
since the Spanish Flu in the 1900s
scientists have predicted that Humanity
will go through another worldwide
pandemic
as Humanity destroys natural habitats
and makes contact with Wildlife it
becomes more likely that we'll contract
diseases from them
and instead of blaming China or other
countries maybe we can take this
opportunity to look at ourselves
maybe countries can use this as a
reminder to invest in things like Public
Health Care More hospitals paid sick
leave
and the protection of Wildlife
because with the way the world operates
pandemics are almost inevitable
we just need to figure out a better way
of handling them
one way would be for everyone in the
world to wear masks
but we'll leave that story for another
what if